gemma es una ecóloga que estudia el
cambio en la población de narvales del
océano ártico a lo largo del tiempo ella
observó que la población pierde 5.6 por
ciento de su tamaño cada 2.8 meses la
población de narvales puede moderarse
con una función n que depende del tiempo
t y está y se mide en meses por supuesto
cuando gm empezó el estudio observó que
había 89 mil árboles en el océano ártico
escribe una función que modele la
población de narvales después de 'the
meses de haber iniciado la investigación
de gemma así que como siempre te invito
a que hagas una pausa y trates de
resolver este problema por tu propia
cuenta muy bien vamos a tratar de
resolver este problema todos juntos y
para tener una noción de cómo se
comporta la función que estamos buscando
siempre es útil una tabla digamos para
ver cuánto vale la función para algunos
valores interesantes así que vamos a
construir nuestra tablita vamos a poner
lado izquierdo el tiempo te que por
supuesto se mide en meses y nd te será
la cantidad de narvales en cada momento
del tiempo muy bien entonces nosotros
sabemos que al tiempo cero es decir al
tiempo digamos en que se inicia la
investigación había 89 mil narval es
verdad entonces tenemos 89 mil árboles
ahora bien nosotros sabemos que la
población pierde 5.6 por ciento de su
tamaño cada 2.8 meses entonces digamos
después de que ocurran 2.8 meses
tendremos que 89 mil perderás 5.6 por
ciento de su tamaño es un porcentaje
cuánto es bueno si nosotros pensamos que
el 100 por ciento pierde 5.6 por ciento
eso nos dice que nos debe quedar un 90 y
4.4 por ciento verdad si nosotros
sumamos 94.4
punto 6 nos da 95 y si luego sumamos el
5% nos da un total de 100 verdad
entonces nosotros podríamos pensar de
forma equivalente que si perdemos 5.6
por ciento de la población esto es
equivalente a decir que la población
inicial se reduce al 90 y 4.4 por ciento
de la población original verdad entonces
aquí tendremos que la cantidad de
narvales son 89 mil x bueno podríamos
poner 94.4 por ciento o también podremos
poner 0.9 44 bien así que esta es la
cantidad de narvales que tenemos después
de 2.8 meses verdad qué pasaría si ahora
tenemos dos veces 2.8 si nosotros
tenemos que han ocurrido en este caso
serían cinco puntos seis meses verdad
entonces tendríamos que multiplicar el
número anterior por cero punto 944
verdad es decir
tendremos que esta población se reduce
otra vez 5.6 por ciento o lo que es lo
mismo multiplicarlo por 0 punto 944
verdad pero 89 mil por 0 punto 944
verdad si lo volvemos a multiplicar por
0 puntos 900 perdón 944 será como elevar
este número al cuadrado que pasa así
ocurren otra vez 2.8 meses
bueno pues otra vez al número anterior
tendremos que multiplicarlo por 0 punto
944 pero aquí teníamos este número al
cuadrado si lo multiplicamos por ese
mismo número tendremos que estará
elevado al cubo entonces como puedes ver
la función del número de narvales
a medida que avanza el tiempo es en
realidad una función exponencial verdad
está digamos cada 2.8 meses se tendrá
que multiplicar por cero
punto 944 verdad entonces en realidad
nuestra función n de t será nuestra
población inicial que son 89 mil que
multiplica a 0.900 44 elevado a un
exponente del exponente corresponde a la
cantidad de veces que han pasado 2.8
meses es verdad y eso lo podemos medir
fácilmente como el tiempo dividido entre
2.8 entonces por ejemplo cuando el
tiempo es cero este número estará
elevado a la cero que es uno y
justamente tenemos la población inicial
cuando han pasado 2.8 meses tendremos
2.8 dividido entre 2.8 y esto nos da una
verdad si por ejemplo t es 5.6 verdad
que es dos veces 2.8 entonces 5.6 entre
2.8 es justamente 2 verdad y eso es
porque han pasado dos veces 2.8
es verdad entonces bueno esta es la
forma de calcularlo y ahí lo tenemos
verdad con esta función ya hemos
modelado el número de narvales que hay
en el océano ártico a lo largo del
tiempo